hey so i did a thing i i watched batman
vs superman ultimate edition
because i was like all right well we're
getting the snyder cut i should probably
re-watch this movie and if i'm gonna
rewatch it i'm gonna watch the
director's cut to see hey what else does
it have going on yeah i should have
watched this a lot earlier
because it's a lot better than the
theatrical version so i'm going to give
you my thoughts on it maybe it's a
review maybe it's not i don't know i'm
probably still going to title it a
review regardless
this is essentially my thoughts just
what my reviews are so if you don't
remember when batman vs superman came
out i was like
this is pretty lackluster considering
it's batman versus superman
then there was this ultimate edition
that had a half an hour
it was half an hour longer that makes
the running time three hours and i was
like
i just don't want to sit through three
hours of that movie i was like okay on
but yeah after watching it that's a
pretty important half an hour of content
damn it okay so
initially when i was watching batman vs
superman at the very beginning you know
lois is in the desert and
just right off the bat in the theatrical
version i'm sitting in the movie theater
and i was like this just feels choppy as
hell yeah because they just
sliced up a bunch of stuff in that scene
which you see in the ultimate edition i
was always like
how how did they frame superman i mean
yeah people died and then i guess they
blamed it on superman but this one
shows them burning bodies in the
ultimate edition they're still gonna
have bullets in their heads but
i imagine no one's gonna do an autopsy
on that [ __ ] i'm sure after the story
lex luthor just had the body shoveled
away or something i don't know point is
while i'm watching ultimate edition i'm
like well that scene was a lot better
let's just see what else they got and it
does have more i mean most of that
extra half an hour is in the first half
of the movie in a lot of
investigative angles everyone's
investigating everyone you know it's
like clark kent is investigating
batman lois lane is investigating the
whole scene at the beginning that frames
superman which is in the theatrical
version but it's just a lot more fleshed
out here actually i said something in my
review of batman vs superman and the
pacing in this movie this movie is two
and a half hours long did it need to be
i guess to cram everything in this movie
that they were cramming into this movie
yeah it had to be two and a half hours
long however there are enough elements
like threads you can just see them
you're like that didn't need to be in
there
they could have taken that out could
have taken that out ah me before
2020 broke me but that phrase is a
double-edged sword when there is
a plot point or a series of plot points
that just feel like
half-assed plot points that are
shoe-horned into a movie the natural
course that i go to is like yeah you
should probably take those out but on
the other side
what you could do is flesh them out and
actually make them relevant i didn't
know it was filmed to be fleshed out and
made relevant and then
sliced up to make the movie shorter and
that's what they did they actually
fleshed out a lot of those investigative
angles and side arcs and
they're actually important in looking
into the batman clark kent actually goes
to gotham and instead of the movie
lightly implying or
telling you that clark kent doesn't
agree with batman it shows how he comes
to the conclusion that this batman is
judge and jury
you know the mark all over guards don't
care that's the judge
he talks to residents who seem scared of
batman i mean what good is the batman if
he makes people afraid it was an
interesting arc whereas in the
theatrical version it was like nobody
cares about clark kent taking on the
batman
okay guess i'll stop good talk so it
does such a good job at illustrating
that clark kent's like this guy
is dangerous he's just a vigilante
criminal that makes everyone feel afraid
all the time and that was just another
scenario where i was like the theatrical
version kind of
implied things whereas the ultimate
edition
you see it it just did a better job at
really showing how batman's going crazy
like someone who's a millionaire in
dresses up like a bat
to scour the rooftops and be a vigilante
already
they're kind of not stable you did a
better job showing after the events
of man of steel batman is losing his
mind he's taken the tumble down to
villainy to the point where
he doesn't necessarily care about the
people as much as he probably did at one
point which means alfred's words of
warning felt more impactful it just
felt like batman's soul was on the line
which makes it more profound the fact
that the one who
saves his soul essentially the one who
helps batman remember how to be a hero
is superman the alien he was hell-bent
on destroying earlier on in the movie
and i know this was all
essentially in the theatrical cut i'm
just saying an extra half an hour of run
time
fleshes it out as an extra half an hour
of run time probably should it's amazing
the difference that half an hour can
make
still not a fan of jesse eisenberg's lex
luthor in fact there are a few things in
the theatrical version if they annoyed
you there
they're gonna annoy you here if you felt
doomsday was shoehorned into the end
you're gonna feel like that here
i'm still in here jesse eisenberg's lex
luthor if you weren't a fan before
you're probably not gonna be a fan now
that's the case with me though
i will say on paper he's lex luthor if
you think of his lines being said from a
lex luthor let's say
the animated series lex luthor yep
michael ironside darkseid animated
series lex luthor pointed as i was i was
a fan of the portrayal
of the villains in that show apparently
if you think of the lines
lex luthor says in batman vs superman
you think of
that lex luthor saying them they are lex
luthor lines his motivation very lex
luthor but that arch enemy
mastermind lex luthor that's on paper in
here just kind of gets
lost behind jesse eisenberg's [ __ ]
betrayal of lex luthor so yeah in the
end finally watch the batman vs superman
ultimate edition the director's cut
essentially of batman vs superman the
three hour cut and the half an hour of
extra footage
it went places it was important stuff it
takes it from feeling like a sloppy mess
to an
interesting dark batman and superman
investigative story like you look at
terminator 2 the terminator 2 director's
cut is a half an hour
longer than the theatrical cut but it
works there were things taken out where
it's like yeah you can take that out you
can do that differently there's a scene
in there that's completely different
with the chip in terminator's head it's
amazing but the point is the theatrical
cut
is coherent and the director's cut just
it gives you more and fleshes it out
same with lord of the rings the lord of
the rings theatrical cuts they work
they're amazing
the director's cut the extended editions
they are better but
either work batman vs superman is like
there's one version that works
and that's the ultimate edition the
director's cut and the theatrical cut
just
there was no way to shave a half an hour
off of that movie and make it coherent
so yeah glad i watched it
finally actually i'm actually bummed out
i didn't watch it earlier could have
spent more time enjoying batman vs
superman rather than being like oh you
mean that sloppy messes out in the
theaters which i do want to clarify here
the snyder cut i saw quite a few
comments in my comment section like well
what's
zack snyder's justice league director's
cut gonna do differently how is it gonna
be different
it's not like this it's not like the
batman vs superman ultimate edition
which is a director's cut of the
theatrical cut no zack snyder film
justice league and then due to a family
tragedy
stepped off of justice league and
instead of warner brothers being like
hey
we'll wait for you you take your time
they were like all right we want to make
our deadlines we'll bring in joss whedon
who re-filmed a lot of the movie and
essentially
made his own movie so the snyder cut
isn't a director's cut of the justice
league movie we got the snyder cuts a
different justice league movie yeah
there's going to be some overlap because
some of snyder's stuff was used in the
justice league movie but also there's
going to be a lot of stuff
in the justice league movie we got
that's not going to be in the snyder cut
snyder
going to have a lot more the context to
scenes that there might be overlap with
is going to be different different thing
altogether so if you hated
batman vs superman maybe it won't sway
you
but if you were just kind of in the
middle like oh okay it's disappointing i
said give the ultimate edition a shot i
walked away from the movie feeling like
i had seen
if not a different movie a much better
movie alright so batman vs superman
the ultimate edition have you seen it
what did you think about it did it make
the movie better did you feel like it's
the same movie but just longer whatever
you thought about it comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you